i don't know how to ask this but you
know joe rogan me
had a had a sense about you similar to
like uh fedor
that you are potentially one of the
greatest ever yeah
does it hurt that you're not in the
discussion now of being in the top 10
yeah
of all time i didn't prove it i don't
deserve it
i mean but i didn't i didn't prove it i
mean and so it's like uh
had i had i somehow gotten to convince
dana white we go and convince him in
2013 to
make me an offer and i didn't even need
a good offer i needed any offer had i
gotten the offer then
maybe the outcome's different right but
given i would never expect anyone to
think of me that way i didn't prove it i
i know i know what i was
and i'm good with that and yeah other
people never got to see that do you
think well you don't know you can't know
fully right do you think if you uh
went to the ufc at that time instead of
one championship i think it had a lot of
success
yeah i mean there's obviously certain
guys there's a lot of guys i've trained
with that
i had a lot of really good results
against and
was a champion for a long time there
so i was around tyrone was a champion
anthony was a champion at lightweight i
was you know the same gym as him and we
had a lot of people coming through
yeah did you face tyron
would i have fought him i don't think so
i mean so he was still the champion when
i came into the dfc and we said no we're
not going to fight
all right
hey so he can't change history right so
once something happens you got to accept
for what it is and move forward and and
obviously hope you can continue to keep
accomplishing great things which for me
obviously my athletic career is over
so now it's going to be through my
wrestling academies and you know who
knows what else i could get into
you